you guys have been asking how the M3 Pro
compares to a Windows laptop say if you
have $2,000 what kind of performance do
you get so we partnered up with Lenovo
and Intel and this is the legion slim 7
an Intel Core I9 laptop that means that
it's Intel's latest hybrid architecture
including pushing gaming performance
this thing packs the Intel I9 13 900h
processor with 14 cores and 20 threads
compared to the M3 Pro in our MacBook
both of these are about $2,000 and as
you can see we have the 14in and of
course you can get a 16in as well but
then you're looking at more money and if
you match up the storage you're looking
at
$2,700 so even though the 16in is the
same weight and size as this Lenovo
Legion 7 slim well price-wise this is
the comparison that matches up now I
have have to say that I was very
impressed with this laptop when I took
it out of the box I think this is the
highest build quality um Windows laptop
that I have ever felt we have a metal
design with pretty much zero flex and it
feels very premium let me go ahead and
close these down of course we have the
logo right here and right over here and
what is crazy cool is that the ports a
lot of them are on the back we have the
HDMI back here and it is HDMI 2.1 just
like on the MacBook we also have three
standard USB type A ports which you
can't get on a Mac and these are all 10
GB per second so they are the fastest
version of these and that is just cool
to have that in the back so you can
connect stuff and keep it out of the way
now the MacBook does have the mag safe
charging connector on the left side
along with two Thunderbolt ports and you
have a headphone jack and then on the
the other side we have an SD card reader
another Thunderbolt and that HDMI now
with the Windows laptop we have two USB
C's on the Le hand side along with the
headphone jack and one cool thing is the
USB type-c over here is actual USB CPD
so you can use that to charge up this
laptop and one of these is a thunderbolt
Port now on the other side we have a
webcam switch that physically
disconnects it for privacy and we also
have a full size SD card reader now you
guys also probably noticed all of the
vents on each side and along the back
and if we go ahead and flip this over we
also have these vents at the bottom here
for cooling and this thing can cool
itself down we have these standoffs here
and if we take a look with the covers
removed you guys can see that that
cooling system is really beefy compared
to the MacBooks we have a lot of heat
pipes there with very large fans now of
course both these are very powerful and
we have a dedicated graphics card built
into the Lenovo laptop so I want to see
how it will do in terms of thermals so I
ran a 10-minute stress test and I was
really impressed by how cool the Lenovo
runs of course the MacBook um they
really care about it being quiet and so
it does get quite hot and if we take a
look at our thermal camera we see that
we have a lot of heat built up and on
the Lenovo those fans move so much air
that there's not a lot of hot zones now
of course running the fans in
performance mode will optimize cooling
for the system and maximize performance
but you can tweak that there's actually
a shortcut right over here you hit
function and then q and you can actually
go into the quiet mode or the auto
balance mode and then we can go back to
the performance mode so if you want to
prioritize the system running quiet you
could do that and in the Lenova Vantage
app we can also change a bunch of
settings including customization for the
back lighting with a lot of different
effects that you can customize we do
have a fingerprint scanner on both these
built into the power button and as far
as the keyboard quality the keys feel
really nice on the Lenovo just like on
the MacBook as far as trackpads we have
the magnetic trackpad here compared to a
standard diving board uh design with the
Windows laptop now as far as RAM we have
18 gigs on the Mac and 16 on the Windows
laptop one very cool thing though is
that you can add an additional RAM
module for only 50 bucks bringing it up
to 32 gigs whereas with the Mac it is
all soldered in so you have to do that
when you purchase and to go up to the
similar level that's going to cost you
$400 now as far as storage both these
use PCI Express 4 and we'll cover the
speeds in just a bit but Intel is now
shipping PCI Express 5 with a 7,000
series chipset plus four lanes of PCI
Express 4 which is up to eight more
Lanes uh but the Mac here at 2 Grand
comes with 512 where you get a terabyte
with the Windows laptop and yes you can
actually add another nvme PC Express 4
and for between 50 to 75 bucks you can
have 2 terabytes compared to the Mac
where you have to do when you buy it
that costs you
$600 the legion 7 slim also has the
biggest battery they can legally bring
onto an airplane so that is really cool
to see and as far as the displays the
Mac has a 14-in 3024 by1 1964 resolution
display that is mini led up to 1600 nits
and it has 120 HZ refresh rate compared
to the 16-in 2560 x600 500 nit LCD that
is srgb 100% so it's tuned from the
factory and this one actually goes up to
2 40 htz now comparing the ssds our
MacBook got 4,600 compared to
5,263 in read and then 4,200 compared to
4,300 for the rights now of course the
Lenovo has a 1 tbte and if you spend
another $200 on the MacBook then the
speeds will kick up now getting into CPU
performance we have the Intel I9
13900 H it's a raptor Lake processor
that hits over 5 GHz at its peak
compared to Apple's M3 Pro in this 14 in
for single core we're looking at
2,778 compared to
3,17 and then as far as multicore we
have
12,34 compared to
13,692 now switching to cinebench 2024
is just going to put a full consistent
load on the CPU we have 1,26 for the
Intel I9 compared 2
8865 4our M3 Pro so the tables have
flipped here because these Intel chips
have more threads and more cores which
is increasing multi-thread performance
for rendering and of course gaming and
now switching over to Graphics we have
the RTX 470 compared to the M3 Pros uh
unified kind of architecture and we have
11,880 compared to
5,463 that's more than twice as is
powerful huge difference and then
looking at gaming performance with gfx
bench as far as a 1440p Aztec Ruins we
have
329.99
point4 that is getting close to twice as
powerful and then for the 4K test we
have 142 FPS compared to 78 Intel is
using the thread director which helps
with background tasks getting rid of
interruptions and smart cash which
accelerates the processor for better fps
and you guys could see the gaming
performance is way better and of course
both of these have Ray tracing so now
let's go ahead and take a look at
blender in party tug the Lenovo took 45
seconds to render this compared to the
MacBook which took
57 seconds so we also see a difference
and keep in mind this is what the M3 Pro
using Ray tracing because the M2 pro
version Well that took 2 minutes and 13
seconds so we saw a big gain but we are
still faster with the Windows machine
now as far as photo editing with Adobe
Lightroom we have a test of 50
highresolution edited raw files and
exporting those took a minute and 19
seconds compared to 45 seconds with the
M3 Pro MacBook now as far as video
editing I'm using denture resolve studio
and for our standard 5 minute 4K test
with effects the Lenovo took a minute
and 5 Seconds to render it compared to a
minute and
21 so it is actually faster and with
that the M3 Pro does have Pro res
encoders but the Lenovo has um av1
encoders built in and decoder so that
helps if you're going to do streaming
and video for online and then to really
see the capabilities of these systems
I'm Den noising 4K Blackmagic raw and
here the Lenovo is getting 15 to 16
frames per second compared to 9 frames
per second on the Macbook so there you
guys go go ahead and let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video